[Music]
there's a first inside out and backwards
at least isn't zipped into his oh
there it is
well there's book smart and then there's
street smart yeah and then there's luke
oh he's just he's just curious that's
all he's got this almost scientific mind
with the thirst
for knowledge
he's like this little einstein
some people ask
why
luke asks
why not
i ask why a lot
promise me that you will stay on him
until this project is done i will but
you might have a little more confidence
in him
no one can hear me now
everybody is stupid except me ha ha i am
funny
so how do i start
what do you think i don't know
mom usually tells me what to do join the
club
i'm kidding i love your mom
we are going to try a new approach this
time now your goal is to create a
display about the life and art of van
gogh right yeah okay you got your poster
board right here
so
pretend you're telling the story of his
life to someone who has never heard of
him what do you put on that board
i see the wheels spinning the sparkles
how do they get the lead and pencils
okay let's try to stay on topic look
what i've built dad dunphy towers 200
condos a happy family and everyone way
to go buddy
i gotta hand it to you honey 24 hours
without video games he's already
contributing to society die die
to be fair he's using his imagination
there's no fire escapes they cut corners
i'll cut your corners
so please i invite you to sit back
relax
and enjoy this
musical trip around the world
[Applause]
wow growing up in america sure is great
but i wish i knew more about the world
me too i think i've got an idea see you
later friend
where are you going
to see the world
china looks interesting i think i'll
land here
bring him down
bring him down
just go with it
hmm
was it as awful as i think
take the flowers
it must have been really hard for you to
be supportive while i made a fool out of
myself oh
come here
luke do you mind we're trying to have a
moment here i can't feel my heart
beating my eyes
in his eyes yes okay we'll get a janitor
so did you set off the firecracker yet
when i do you won't have to ask
first all the electrons will go out
then comes the heat flash
afterwards the living will envy the dead
and yet i'm the one on the no fly list
after this we're gonna have some angry
birds
it's gonna be bye bye
birdie a big musical from the 60s no
forget it what you said
okay
okay cool
that's it i'm sorry buddy i brought that
thing all the way from whoa
what are you guys fighting about okay so
we both think that this would make a
totally awesome bed but only one of us
can have it don't you think it should be
me oh so not it should be me right luke
why do you guys want to move into the
attic oh you mean the penthouse with all
the privacy of being on its very own
floor is kind of cool
i'm not an idiot i knew what they were
up to
but i've been wanting to move for a
while
there's a line of ants going to a
trick-or-treat bag in my closet and i
don't want to still be there when they
get tired of candy
hey
what you doing plane
yeah
do you have any money saved up
i'm comfortable
i've saved 1 217
it wasn't even that hard don't forget
your lunch
thanks mom
don't forget your lunch money buddy
thanks dad
please it's really important
look i'd love to help you out but i'm
not very liquid right now it's in a
block of ice i got the idea when i heard
about rich guys with frozen assets
assets
mom something's on my mind and it's
really bothering me yeah it's really
bothering me too but i think it's gonna
be rich so we better be nice to it i
want to quit magic
what
i'm not really interested anymore but i
don't think dad's gonna be happy oh
sweetheart don't worry about
disappointing your father he only wants
you to do it if you want to do it tell
you what i will talk to dad whoa
talk to dad that sounds serious
don't do drugs stay in school
luke wants to quit magic that's not
happening well see you guys at dinner
sweetheart don't you even want to talk
about this what's to talk about the
kid's unnatural he has everything the
hands the pattern the outfits okay let's
play this out even if he is one in a
million what's our best case scenario
here he becomes what a professional
magician
honey the boy has a gift you want to
just throw that away i don't think it's
about throwing it away i think it's
better i guess any of this i'm sorry i
don't like magic as much as you but i
don't this isn't about magic no it's
about my life and you controlling it
look you made a commitment you will
honor that commitment ugh i hate it here
hulk
his door is still closed what is he
doing in there i think we both know what
he's doing in there he's been at it for
hours and so i was at his age he's going
to wear himself out you should talk to
him i don't want to embarrass him so
knock first maybe right i don't know i'm
doing it wrong i'm getting hurt
luke
i'm coming in
hey man
buddy
dad get out of here don't be embarrassed
son it's perfectly natural
i know you two threw a party i don't
throw a party claire it's true he can't
throw anything and if i were hosting an
event where did i put the ice sculpture
where did i stash your hors d'oeuvres
where did i hide the jazz trio good
question considering you couldn't even
hide
the solo
nice wordplay mom but that cub's been
there for like three days i didn't want
to say anything cause i thought it was
yours
yeah it was bold but those kids upstairs
weren't gonna stay quiet forever i was
one dead phone battery away from a
conversation breaking out
sure throwing a party was a risk but two
hot exchange students just started at
our school best part is they don't
understand just how uncool we are
yet
so we were walking down the hallway when
we stopped by the loft oh
pizza day
hmm
that's our personal trainer he hates it
when we eat carbs we had a short window
we needed to impress them fast so we
bribed lilly with all the soda she could
drink and through a party it was going
great until someone set off the alarm
because he just had to smoke his dorky
pipe dorky yeah because hugh hefner
doesn't get girls
i love you too
mommy all clear party people
i told her we were baking cookies dude
our oven's broken my mom's definitely
gonna get suspicious and check on us
that means my mom's coming too
i'll get everyone to leave you get rid
of the beer and your idea of a spread
wait
we're not giving up yet the beer pong
tournament just started the girls are
laughing at all of our jokes and they
think we're friends with guys like tommy
cudahy
great party lewis
thanks tommy from now on i'm louis we're
going to get caught if we do nothing
what if we hide everyone long enough for
my mom to check on us and then leave
it's not worth it guys
when do we play seven hours in heaven
moving the party upstairs people
explain yourself i'm taking photos of
your feet for perverts ew hear me out
remember when you couldn't return those
sneakers you bought and asked me to sell
them online
right after i listed them i got a
message asking if they'd been worn and
sweat in before i could lie and say no
i got another message can i see your
feet
apparently there are a ton of these feet
freaks on the internet oh my god did you
write this my little piggies got so
sweaty sexy right no no it's gross that
pair of sneakers went for over 200
i have more in my closet
that was three weeks ago and we have
made a ton of money since all i have to
do is wear a different shoe every day
hitting all the right notes
ship it
well luke i read your essay
took a lot of guts to admit you weren't
ready for college a year ago
i had a lot of growing hep to do so i
got a job i paid my bills and i read the
wall street journal online until i used
up my five free articles well based on
your credit score we'd like to welcome
you to sequoia community college
thank you and once you walk through one
of our 15 tsa approved metal detectors
anything is possible
how hard is it well most of our students
report about 10 to 15 hours of homework
a week in addition to class time that
sounds like real college this is a real
college
and it's a lot of hard work but you put
in your two years here then transfer to
a real
to a four-year college and you will land
an entry-level job nothing too glamorous
but you pay your dues and climb the
ladder by the time you're 45 you're
living in a three-bedroom house with a
picket fence wow
three-bedroom house with a picket fence
already got one of those
plus free meals laundry and cable i am
living the dream you know what i say
whom needs college
what kind of gym bag is that anyway it's
a satchel you ignorant sneeze
you have been so unpleasant lately
on a definitely related note manny
hasn't got any action in months
well
other than whatever gave him carpal
tunnel luckily the prescott has an 80s
aerobicized class which will be full of
single older ladies
women hit a sweet spot right after 40
where they still look great but their
standards have lowered
you're in pretty good shape for someone
who's 42 43 i'm 38.
bye
oh there you are sorry you missed you at
the bowling alley
she looked different with a headband on
warming up in a hot tub first
unconventional hey anything to loosen up
becks did we meet a becky maybe there
were so many of them
so how old is this x 44
it's on
oh there you are
wait
your backs
yep and i'm eager to learn a warning my
form's clumsy but i'm great on my feet
hi mommy and daddy we know you don't
think that we can take care of a dog but
you haven't met our dog wolfy
no barking wolfy but you just said to
him bad dog
bad dog oh
no and don't worry we'll always remember
to feed him and keep him healthy is
there a pill in here so you don't want a
shiny coat you guys are probably worried
he's going to get the house all dirty
well we know how to handle that wait how
are we going to drop
so as you can see we can do this we know
a dog's a lot of work but we'll never
have to do it alone yeah it will always
be the three of us
always
the end
you guys know you can call me anytime
right
and it's easy to visit switzerland so
and i can still count on you for
relationship advice right
i don't want to become one of those
pathetic guys that lets women manipulate
them
we're gonna be fine
sit
stay
um
[Music]
you